a lyon rien ne va plus chez majorette
cette petite entreprise qui fabrique
vous le savez les petites voitures que
nous connaissons tous les employés
redoutent visiblement la vente de leur
société le tribunal de commerce avait
choisi la société idéale loisirs pour
reprendre majorettes
aujourd'hui les salariés cherchent à
faire appel de cette décision
ils craignent à terme d'être dix ans
yves à lyon françois vallet les salariés
de majorette ne comprennent pas cette
décision du tribunal de commerce de
céder leur entreprise a aidé à loisir
parmi tous les repreneurs en lice eux
s'étaient prononcés à 90 % pour le
groupe
thirion son plan prévoyait sans
suppressions d'emplois sur les 690 que
compte majorettes et sa filiale solido
le plan du bernard par case pdg d'idéal
loisirs prévoit 200 suppressions
d'emplois 135 personnes viennent d'être
licenciés
actuellement en france dont l'un des
gros problèmes d'emploi et on comprend
pas que le choix du tribunal se soit
porté pour un repreneur qui ne
préservait pas le maximum d'emplois
ce qui nous inquiète c'est la
délocalisation monsieur farkas il a une
production quand même à 70% en haïti
donc nous on se demande de quelle
manière il pourrait justifier une
production française et c'est une plus
grande frayeur de savoir patrie il a
fait quand même dans ces licenciements
fait partir les moules ce qui est de
savoir faire de chez majorette inquiets
de voir partir leur production à
l'étranger
les salariés ont donc décidé de faire
appel ils demandent l'annulation de la
décision du tribunal de commerce
ensemble nous ne souhaitons pas faire de
la procédure pour faire de la procédure
considérons que la pérennité de cette
entreprise passe par le maintien d'un
certain nombre d' un certain nombre
d'emplois si l'appel des salariés est
recevable le dossier sera réexaminé par
la chambre commerciale de la cour
d'appel
c'est elle qui décidera si la tortue
ninja au secours de la petite voiture
est un bon choix